Hello everybody!
Hi!
Hi hi!
Hello, hello, hello!
Having a monkey of a time today.
Yes, we are.
Looking cute in summary today.
I have my cardigan on though.
More fun than a barrel of monkeys.
Wait, did anybody else play that game?
Beryl of monkeys?
I love that game.
Actually...
Yeah.
I love that game.
It's a bit of an early stream today.
It's a classic.
Yeah, you remember it?
Yeah, you like grab the monkey and you try to see how many
other monkeys you can pull out of the barrel.
I think that's how you played it, right?
I think I just poured them out and played with the little
monkeys.
Me too.
I'd also do that.
Yeah.
A stream full of ice cold shenanigans.
Because it's hot.
It's summer and it's warm.
So I want to be with the ice monkey today.
Even though I was looking at him.
Look.
I haven't upgraded him at all.
We need to get our ice monkey up.
Wait, can I upgrade this guy?
Oh, I can.
boomerang monkey and also who the heck is this desperado but
who are you mint help me off cry so soon there's so much
stuff happening it's overwhelming can't wait to see you at
the concert though don't be overwhelmed um oh if you're
overwhelmed it helps to make a schedule of everything and
you can then even if things overlap you can be like you can
be like oh well I I'm feeling more of this today than not
today so you know thank you can I get some monkey noises how
was that I was a professional monkey by the way I was I was
curious George for one day I got to climb on a table tables
and chairs.
I'm a professional monkey.
Mito, you're one level away.
From what?
I don't look, I don't look.
Miss Mickey Phantom, an apple a day keeps Dr. Gay.
So says Mr. Short.
Stort.
Wait, who is this?
Congrats on the Ori song, Absolute Banger.
Thank you!
Have you gotten the Ice Monkey Hero?
There's no hero?
Wait.
Unless it's this.
This is not my Ice Monkey.
Hello, Mito and I pose like you.
Looking positively cute.
And I have the new song on repeat.
All day.
We cannot get tired of it.
Also, twice the Minky one day.
Yippee!
Yeah!
Later on, I'll be playing Power World.
with the gals, the gal world, you might want to say.
It's me, Matara, Doki, Lime, I almost said sloppy.
Me, Matara, Doki, Lime, Snuffy, and Nimi.
Yeah, sloppy sisters plus Nimi plus Matara.
I'm still deciding if I want to If I rather if I can stream
my POV today Because for it I might have to leave early To
get some things I have so much to do before Off Guy And I
only have today and tomorrow So I focused all energy on
Outfit and now I'm like I have more to do
So, one stinky minkey jumping on the bed, she jumped off and
lost her head.
The super sloppies.
Yeah, sloppies extended.
What do we call this new arrangement, the sloppy six?
Is there six of us?
Wait, that's so fun.
Okay.
Sloppy plus.
Sloppy new game plus.
And that's how Vicky came to be.
Oh, she was jumping on the bed?
That's so bad.
I like jumping on the bed.
This is not my ice monkey.
We will just be base ice monkey.
But I think we have to train a little bit.
And then whoever the heck this guy is.
I can't Wait
I need him I need I'm desperate For him My brain is so off I
have checked out the work I checked out of work mentally
Help The Q and death is Helping me get stuff done though
Thanks for the ori song Thank you for listening to it Thank
you Thank you I need A wanderer works best alone.
Desperado attacks much faster, but less so when more monkeys
are in each weapon's attack range.
Fun fact, Minto is subscribe to your channel during the last
Blune TG6 stream.
How long ago was that?
When was that?
Too long?
I'm sorry!
Thank you, Phil!
Thank you!
Was Does that stop getting pregnant?
I keep getting freaky accounts of people being like, oh,
Minto looks pregnant in the thumbnail of her original song.
But that's just how dresses work when they blow in the wind.
And so I keep, I get some weird, like, pregnant fetish
people being like, she looks pregnant.
She looks pregnant.
Get out of here!
The dress is pregnant.
Yeah, yeah.
I...
I think you just see what you want to see.
Maybe.
You know what I mean?
Monkey Village!
Let's go.
Don't look at... Now that I... I almost didn't bring it up
because I was like, now people will look at it and see that.
but I also think it's kind of funny definitely them seeing
things I think so too the eye sees what or the heart sees
what the heart wants
maybe I never thought that when watching I'm glad then I'm
glad no I'm not acknowledging that even if it's pink I'm not
I'm not
It's been a bit since I've last played.
Wait, there's some new ones!
Skull tweak!
Let's go too!
Let's do...
We can do a new one and we can just get our ice monkeys up.
Ice monkey only.
Mostly.
I think I have to be able to afford...
I can't afford the ice monkey!
Do you think I could kill him, though, with just him?
Larger radius.
Wait, they can't!
Actually, wait.
They can't...
They can't pop, can they?
I have to upgrade them to pop.
That's right.
I just remembered.
We'll...
We'll do it like this.
It might be a rough start.
Don't worry about it.
Oh, he can!
He claps.
Just kidding.
Okay.
We'll sell this guy eventually.
We have to get up to all full ice monkeys.
They can on regular balloons.
Yes.
Yeah.
Okay.
Another next ice monkey.
This is perfect placement.
Please understand.
Nice.
Our
monkey is...
just for moral support at the moment as we gather our ice
monkey our ice monkey army
see this is good this is good this is good in fact I'll put
another guy in the corner here actually I want what we're
trying to do is get more exp for ice monkey ice monkey has
nothing what is this now Loon's move slowly even after
thawing out.
Aha!
She's not pregnant, she's just a whole watermelon in one
gulp.
Because it's summer and it's really hot outside.
I've never done that in my afterlife.
That sounds like a Looney Tunes thing.
Roadrunner cartoons.
Roadrunner cartoons!
Oh, it feels...
something about this just feels right being back in balloons
you know what i mean okay hold on one thing i do have to
also see is i i went for this one before maybe this is the
thing to go for this is this is what i was working towards
so we'll go larger radius with this guy refreeze oh look at
his sick glasses so far so good again oh it's been a many
many moons since I've last played
she's in her element he's got the freak glasses yeah that's
not very nice attacks faster and freezes for longer this
kind might be our OP monkey.
Many bloons ago.
Many bloon moons ago.
Let's also go on.
Snowstorm ability.
Briefly freezes white zebra and camo and slows Moab.
Now will I be able to attack mmm?
Attack camo.
Can freeze and pop lead and camo?
Okay, okay.
We're going to have to to get this cold snap like that okay
at least this guy oh my god wait a little snake yeah we need
that we need that
hold on i get more money he's not even looking though he's
like they've got it they've got it he wasn't even looking
this way
recommended 205 ice monkey yes that's what i'm doing this
guy 205 i think i might even do this guy also but what's the
middle one oh the snowstorm
oh it's greatly increased wait we want absolute zero
eventually we have to work our way up there We have a full
Ice Monkey team.
All Ice Monkeys' attack speed would greatly increase.
It'd be great.
Did you know they added an Ice Monkey Paragon?
Wait, what does that mean?
Normal monkey just chilling in the nest while the ward goes
on outside.
Or protect the princess, protect the princess.
I love when they juggle.
Are you too cool to juggle?
Are you too cool for that?
Freezes water nearby.
Interesting.
We do have this.
This is quite the map now, isn't it?
Um.
We're gonna go...
What's this one?
Hit Moab Class Bloons.
And I did say only Ice Monkeys, but we will also do...
Um...
What's the words?
Farms and banks and monkey village.
Those are allowed.
But as for monkeys, only ice monkey.
Banana farm.
Okay.
We're gonna work for Desperado.
I think we have to unlock him.
Whoa.
We have...
This guy should not have...
Okay.
He's sub 100.
But he should not have...
He should not be...
Lips in a little bit.
finger I think thank you for being you of the amazing new
song in an outfit thank you pancakes thank you yeah we have
to pop them it's like million of balloons or something oh
don't juggle like you didn't just let that thing get away
handle it it's okay these are the growing pains oh my gosh
wait our monkeys are are struggling right now, I think.
I want to get another guy.
Yes.
Okay.
All right.
I don't want to spend all...
I got to spend my money on upgrades.
They're too fast.
You got this?
You don't got this.
Oh my gosh.
It's so over.
Hello?
Monkeys?
What are we doing out here?
I don't pay.
I'll pay you to juggle!
I'll pay you to pop the balloons!
What are we doing?
You know what would help?
Another ice monkey.
Ice monkey can go on water.
He can?
Wait, I'll test once I get the money too.
Look at that.
Only...
Why are you juggling like that?
Slowest balloon ever.
Oh, because they freeze it!
Oh my gosh, huge.
Can you tell I've never used Ice Monkey before?
He can, he can, he can.
That's huge.
That's so much more real estate.
We've got...
But let's, let's, uh...
Again, I gotta, I gotta upgrade my monkeys.
Oh, they're fast!
Oh my god, get it!
Handle it!
Ah!
Oh, the heart is so over.
Oh, they got it.
Wow, they got it.
That was crazy.
Why are you so expensive?
Paragon is Fusion a 3-max ice monkey.
Oh, that's right.
Thank you.
Wait, so if we get the 3, then...
Oh, it's the ultimate ice monkey.
Costs a lot of money, though.
I don't even have the ultimate...
Unlocked, though, at the moment.
We really have our work cut out for us.
It probably won't happen today.
In fact, I'm for certain it won't.
I need Desperado.
I need him right now.
Please, please, please.
We do have the...
Why is it, like, yelling at me?
Oh.
It wants me to unlock eventually.
I'm working on it.
Jeez.
So impatient.
The more money you spend, the monkeys you sacrifice, the
higher level pyrogon you get.
Yeah, we need to farm a ton of HP.
Oh gosh, they're getting so fast!
Wait, monkeys can't keep them!
You got this, you got this, you got this!
Oh no, oh no, a couple...
Oh geez, oh geez!
Come on, come on!
What did I...
What did I bring you into this world for?
more ice monkeys clear oh oh it's over guys oh seven oh
seven in the chat
i'm going to Japan like December so wondering if you have
any wrecks of places i should visit thank you mark have fun
places oh gosh is it your first time going because you could
do You could go anywhere.
We've popped 2,000 out of 3 million bloons, guys.
That's our goal.
Ice Monkey is too chill.
Maybe Skull Tweek was a tough start.
I did go on Medium, to be fair.
Maybe I should do Easy so that we can actually, you know.
Hashtag, ouch.
So that we can get the XP.
Ice Minky bought him, right?
Yeah?
Okay.
All right, let's back our guy back there.
Oh, they're cheaper!
He's not 400 anymore.
All right.
Second Ice Minky.
Deployed.
Easy won't provide much EXP.
I guess that's true maybe I'm maybe I'm I'm thinking too
grand maybe it maybe for my for my level I have too high of
hopes maybe I truly do need to have not just ice monkey but
many more all right we leave maybe maybe I have I have you
know yeah we gotta take it slow.
I can't just I can't just jump right in.
I can't just have a full army of ice monkeys immediately.
Does it matter if I do like a tough math?
Honestly, I like this one.
I want to try it more.
You need Silas, but ice monkey.
I haven't bought him actually.
I can't afford him.
We'll try it.
We'll try him.
winter okay silas you better be good because i really like
sada i'm a sada believer forever
i'm gonna still go medium for now we'll go medium so that we
can i can again it's been a long time since i played sada is
so awesome dang he's expensive oh wow
Ice monkey is totally cracked.
Really?
I'm so excited!
Okay.
Alright.
How do I want to start this then?
I could just start with an ice monkey.
Yeah, I gotta save up for him.
Maybe then we do, like, a cheap dart monkey.
And then I can save up.
I feel like I...
No.
Oh, dang.
We're getting there.
I do use a...
Hmm.
The Tunit Ice Monkey.
Is he really?
Can he put Silas on the water too?
Well, it won't let me try yet.
We don't know.
This is great because we can line this area with sniper
monkeys.
Wait, can sniper monkey go?
No!
What?
This is the perfect place for a sniper monkey.
Are we for real?
Oh, sniper monkeys can also go up here.
Ice monkey in front of the skull.
Right here?
That's sick.
That's metal.
I'm trying to decide just what monkey I go first with, you
know?
I
go with first.
This guy, I don't even think I've used Murmunky before.
Yeah, like two times, maybe.
Murmunky.
Okay.
I think I'm just gonna go dart monkey well we can get rid of
him later we can get rid of him later I just need the money
I want Silas but I don't even know what he does like I don't
know what where it was a good pot place to put him baby core
thank you so much for the gifted classic dart monkey yeah I
just need to make some money.
Abilities.
Oh, you're so right.
Attacks of magical ice.
Hit blooms are rimmed.
Already rimmed blooms are frozen.
Already rimmed and frozen blooms burst into ice explosion.
Buffs all range of all ice monkeys and grants.
More hero XP for each tier 3 ice monkey.
Which we should have a bunch of them.
Ice walls form on the track near Silas.
Walls push back.
and freeze blooms.
Moabs are frozen for less time.
Why less time?
Wait, what does that mean?
What is...
Wait, oh yeah, you're right.
It's only one M.
What does it mean?
I was like, what is it?
I was like, rimmed with ice.
Rime is a kind of ice.
I never knew.
That doesn't mean you have the corner.
Can you do me a favor and click the bottom left, top right,
top left, bottom right, pools of water, then click the nest.
bottom left
rimmed with ice is a way different thing is it?
It's not just you have a rim of ice like on you know like
background the BGM changes and the map becomes harder you
unlock you almost unlock super hard mode wait what?
wait actually you have to click before starting the map
match.
Wait.
Is it actually real?
I feel, okay, I need one more monkey.
We'll just put like a dart monkey right there.
As backup.
Yeah.
I knew I would need the backup.
We just need the money.
Oh my gosh, we're so close, please.
I panicked.
I panicked monkeyed.
I panic monkeyed.
I lost so much money.
Okay, hold on.
Yippee!
Okay, come here.
Whoa.
Whoa, can I put him on the nest?
Where's the best place?
He can go in the water.
This is a not bad spot, though, because you get all this
area and then you get all this a little bit of here right
let's try it bottom left pool oh because you then you get
all of this but i guess you don't get inside yeah because
it's red maybe like here sleek and sharp and made of winter
come holy holy cow does he sound like shadow oh my gosh wait
gonna start packing for all kind of officially leaving home
tomorrow can't wait to see you there and see the concert
managed to get a concert ticket so good see you there see
you there no wait he insane he's he's abs he's crazy mode I
like having an ice monkey here it makes me feel safe he's
he's insane oh style even colder even colder even colder I'm
gonna do two five here look
how slow they are so slow they are oh my god he He's insane.
What did it say?
We need a tier three.
Yeah, camel balloons.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, you don't think he has it.
Okay, good to know.
He cannot pop white balloons or purple balloons.
Thank you.
Thank you, everybody.
We do at least now have the lead and camel.
Oh, whoa.
Wow.
Forget work, return to balloon plopper.
Just dropping by to say hi, Minto.
Hi, Marco.
Thank you.
Back to work.
Got one hour, 30 minutes left.
Good luck.
The addiction is calling.
For white balloons, use his skill.
Actually, what is his skill?
Let's have a bit of fun.
Right now he's at, oh, he's at level three already.
Hit all balloons while active.
When hitting frozen balloons, target takes extra damage
based on remaining free, Okay, okay.
Yes, yes, yes, they're so cold and they don't move.
Oh my gosh, he's cracked!
This is awesome!
Okay, I almost...
Why, why...
Hold on, I'm blocking a little bit.
Actually, this is a good spot because there's no bloons that
come behind my head.
Um, only monkeys.
But...
Why must farm be so expensive?
As king, I hereby grant a mint honorary monkey statue.
Statue.
Stat.
Status.
And the title of Duchess Mint of the Ice Monkey Legion.
Oh, hail the monkey king!
Ice monkey close to him to get a buff.
Yeah, let's buff him.
Let's buff him.
Buff, buff.
Wait.
Oh, there we go.
My game was not moving for some reason.
Oh, he's buffed.
He's buffed.
He's so strong.
Buff, buff, buff, buff.
Wait, is this still in range?
Okay, this is not.
Oh, dang it.
He's so, he's still in range here.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
I just, it's pixel perfect.
There.
I'll just put him down.
He's, he's, he's support.
He's support.
look at him go he's support he's support
okay we are making a decent XP we should be able to get
snowstorm or embrittlement fairly soon so good for morale
Konnita Konnita should probably have an ice monkey above the
hero oh we're gonna fill this whole thing with ice monkeys I
think for subs they might go...
Wait, do we already have the upgrade?
Wait, that's crazy!
I'm gonna save up, though.
I'm gonna save up for Icycle Impale.
Very, very nice.
Uh, refreeze.
We got our sick glasses back.
Whoa!
Holy cow.
Embrylman for Moabs.
Oh, I mean, all of these can go for Moabs.
Oh, this one slows only Moabs.
This one, the icicles does double down.
Actually, well, I still think I want to save up for icicle
impale.
He participated?
Yeah, he did.
He did an amazing job.
You're so awesome ice monkey.
I think for him...
I'm trying to decide what I want to We might also do 2-5 for
him as well.
Yeah.
Sintillating.
What does that?
He's speaking languages, I don't know.
I go for embridlement since it opens up 402 anti-Moaib frost
monkeys.
Wait, what?
Wait, what was the second path?
Deep freeze.
Hmm.
Okay, okay.
Oh, there's a little thing in the road.
This guy has those SAT words.
It means sharp.
Oh, to be sharp.
Sinti- Sorry, I clicked the button.
Sinti-lighting.
Oh!
You know, Ibu, they're extremely scintillating.
Tantalizing.
Then probably...
Let's put another ice monkey here.
This guy will be our...
This one.
So then I will upgrade Embrytalment.
Whoa.
Not bad, not bad.
This lady means sparkling.
Wait, sparkling or sharp?
Wait.
No, no.
Oh, now I'm confused.
You
guys would be terrible in the spelling bee.
Can I have it in a sentence?
Holly said it was...
What is needed?
Holly said was one thing.
I'm also going to put another ice monkey right here.
Can I fit two in here?
You think I can fit two?
Pixel perfect?
I wish I could turn monkeys.
Whoa!
Wait, why is this one that- we're- they're both buffing him
though?
Lost fight.
Stop them.
Oh shoot.
Guys, it's over.
I didn't notice.
Ah, I didn't notice that they were coming through.
We'll restart.
But we'll do it.
Same thing.
Ish.
My ultimate enemy.
Round 22.
Okay, round 22.
This is fine.
The crests of waves and the tips of the ice coals both
scintillating in the Arctic morning.
There.
Now spell it.
Can
even any guy...
I don't want to lose a single life.
Sorry, I wasted money, but it's fine.
Rock!
Fair, I was at the spelling bee and I was really scared.
I think I need two here.
Oh, just kidding.
Dang it.
Oh, I should have waited.
My bad.
Go away.
I need 850.
I'm not doing this very strategically, but don't worry about
it.
Don't worry about it.
We'll make the money back.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Alright.
Watch this.
Apparently YouTube didn't like my original 100% say so
question I was gonna super serious.
So I will just say new Aminto outfit is beautiful.
What?
What were you gonna say?
See losing the spelling bee but winning my heart.
Alright here's where it's getting serious guys.
It's gonna get serious.
We're gonna get serious.
And I'm so serious.
I'm not even going to put ice monkey here as I've been
doing.
Ice monkey goes in the front.
The ice.
What my goal is is to get this guy high, high, high.
And then also to buff our guy with more ice monkeys.
So we will focus on him and adding more monkeys in.
Actually, can they go like right here?
Now that I think about it, isn't this a...
This is a...
Yeah, they can!
We can fill this hole!
Wait.
We can just, like, fill this area.
Range of his attack.
Yes.
Yes, I believe so as well.
So all this is good.
Well, all this is good.
Here's good.
Wait.
Let's do it now.
Let's see.
Okay.
Oh, he's not in range anymore.
He's not in range.
I'm here to help.
Oh my gosh, he's soloing, basically.
It's crazy.
Yeah, I'll make the ice.
It can still do here, probably here even.
Hold on, we'll see in a second.
Yeah.
buff all through here we can there's so much to buff buff
here here here here here here here not here here here here
here here here in the water
probably get i
was only able to do one here unfortunately that we lost this
guy but it's okay i feel like we've gained a bunch of other
spots actually
oh oh oh ice monkey best strategy ever i agree i agree for
now um maybe
yeah so i'm thinking if you go five on the top is is five
two oh the strat yes
okay then i will go with that for this guy oh look at those
little earmuffs It's so cute.
Freeze and pierce deeply.
He's so awesome.
Embrytalment is so useful.
Is it?
Okay, awesome.
My first time ever seriously considering Ice Monkey, you
guys.
He's an expensive little guy, for sure, too.
Silas is...
I'm here to help.
Yeah, you are helping, man.
You are crazy.
this guy is so strong
okay we need 1500 but I'm also I'm actually gonna put
another I'm gonna put a monkey we're gonna start we're gonna
start down the line wait wait wait no way wait I can do the
entire row I thought these were rocks that they couldn't go
up on oh my god oh it's a game changer whoa crazy can he
even hit anything though I guess I can
wait he's not buffed wait did I put him in the wrong spot
oops here we'll make the money back there's still one single
balloon out of buff range no I literally had it right here
there we go okay we're fine we're fine
come on oh no i
had to i had to do it stop
buying new monkeys if you're not leaking well i was first
off and then also i said my strat i wanted a monkey to buff
and i wanted to focus on this guy you aren't listening with
your ears this guy will be my five my 205 and this will be
my two My five, two, oh, jeez.
Scintillating.
Monkey people are...
Bloons people are so crazy.
He said the thing.
Scintillating.
How did you miss him?
Keep going.
Okay.
we're at 20.
We'll do the ability as soon as 22 starts.
And we'll also make it slow.
So if I am leaking anything, I can I can handle it.
Okay.
We're close to be able to get that.
I probably should smaller ice bombs over longer range.
Woo!
What's this removes camo and regrow properties when damaging
balloons okay okay i almost want to eventually i want to put
another one of these guys right here okay
feel the bitter cold feel the bitter cold
i need you to do that again oh shoot no no oh no oh no no
I think it's
just...
Maybe the one, though.
They're breaking through.
Oh, no.
It's not just the one.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Who can I throw in there?
Hmm.
We just took some big old damage.
Yeah, it was my mistake.
I pressed it too early.
To be fair, I only used it once and it was under absolute
panic.
So I don't know how it works, but thanks.
Thanks for pointing it out.
It's my mistake, yeah.
He's just 11 damage.
I know it's a number of layers, isn't it?
So it's like 11 layers or whatever.
Yeah.
It's a learning process.
Exactly.
We're learning Ice Monkey today, everybody.
We are learning Ice Monkey today.
I want...
What is... Well, we... This is... Okay.
Oh, shoot.
There's more.
Okay, wait.
Wait!
This is the ability.
Rust bite.
Can you still grab him?
I'm gonna need Ice Monkey down here to handle it.
actually get a dizzy handle oh gosh it's so over breaking
through it's so over it's so over even colder it's so over
no i lost the money
silas you are so great but you don't regen hearts Oh,
now he's tier three.
So he's, uh, he's getting the buff.
He's getting the buff.
Yes.
I'm here to help.
What?
What level are you at?
Level five.
Level seven, he gets shattering, creates a shattering blast
of ice around Silas and then other ice monkeys spreading out
from Silas.
Frozen Bloom.
extra damage okay cool he's here to help it might be so over
but we're fine maybe oh oh frostbite oh no wait oh i saw the
zebra ones i thought that oh i saw the zebra ones i thought
it was over it cooled down pretty fast though it might be
okay Yes, keep slowing this.
Yes, yes.
1900.
Yes.
Holy beast!
But I am faster.
He's going crazy.
This is...
It sucks when you have the one balloon that's so slow.
All right.
Upgrade.
Good job.
Good job getting those lead balloons.
Yes.
Okay, next comes in.
Wait, when does a Moab...
When does a...
When do we get the Moab?
Three.
Two.
wait maybe i'm okay i was gonna use it i didn't need to oh
my gosh wait how is this guy getting buffed yes what is yeah
i have questions what is your range okay fierce
a level six i'm here to help can attack balloons in the
range of ice monkeys anywhere
what wait maybe i should put like one right like you know oh
my gosh wait i mean he's on it's fine right now wait that's
craziness wait that's crazy
does he gain their ability too so he can attack
that's submarine good for real yeah he's ice submarine it's
crazy wait that's crazy what were we getting next oh 2300 oh
those are camos okay we're good wait this guy was attacking
too though no am i crazy
ah it's time white balloons are less resistant to ice
attacks monkeys at freeze okay so he does get the Bloons.
You're crazy either way, though.
Let's just keep going.
And we're broke again.
Let's go, Embroodalman!
Watch the Z boys.
We're okay, we're okay for now.
Okay.
Whoa, a little fast.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
We'll get to icicle soon.
This guy is just sitting here as OOO monkey.
He's like, I'm just here to have fun.
What are we at for our XP anyway?
Wait, we're almost there!
We're almost there for this one.
Oh, 20... Oh, 20...
25.
I thought it was 20.
Just kidding.
But still!
I could also unlock Snowstorm.
Do you allow monkey village buffs?
I do.
I just haven't set them up yet.
I'm trying to... I wonder, like, where's a good place?
I guess, like, if you put it here and get a couple...
I guess... I don't know.
These ledges look like they could hold a monkey, but I don't
think they can.
They cannot.
Ice monkey so cold mint needs her card again.
Their ice cold.
Plantations I feel can go up here.
Maybe I should start building them all.
Let me actually I'll get this guy up to icicles and then
we'll start.
Well I think I can do one.
No no no.
I'm gonna do it with the icicles.
first.
I'll feel safer.
Okay, now we're good.
Our ice monkey challenge.
Wait, it's actually happening!
This is so awesome!
Oh, he leveled up.
Wait, what's this one?
Okay, wait.
I gotta remember which one of these, what these are.
Moab soon, Moab soon.
okay hold on it's monkey wall wall street i think
is it coming
how far are you planning on going in rounds however long I
can is next round moab we're gonna handle it let's get this
one I want to know what the
we'll let you get it little guy I don't think he even did it
yippee
we're close we're close we're close should we start getting
another well maybe some more nears
our smokey challenge is in full effect baby I can't see what
he looks like as he like upgrades you know wait what are his
outfits I didn't see
yeah I'm quickly becoming a Silas believer there's one that
picks up bananas around which one is it though uncollected
bananas auto collect so like maybe 2 0 5 he's very Oh
really?
I haven't played in so long, I thought it was a new ice
monkey.
I'm like, who are you?
203 or 023?
203?
Oh yes, yes, yes.
Or 023?
Okay, okay, okay.
We'll do!
For now, I'll just...
Oops, I'll do it.
This?
I'm deciding?
Yeah!
0, 2, 3 is better for long term.
Okay.
Gosh, everybody knows the strats.
You guys are so smart.
I'm just listening to what you guys have to say.
I want to try the new one.
Wait, what does it do?
Yes.
Yeah, I'm asking.
Frozen Cascade creates a shattering blast of ice around
Silas than other ice monkeys spreading out from Silas.
Frozen Blue and Sake Extra now.
Oh.
I think we're good.
in the next one.
Auto-collecting.
Actually, oh, it is.
Well, kind of.
Yeah, it is.
Okay.
Two.
Yeah.
Okay.
That one's good.
Upgrade the Ice Monkey.
It's time.
It's his time to be upgraded.
What do we upgrade him to, though?
This...
Oh, we're... We're like...
We're so close.
Why are my bananas so...
Oh, I forgot that I think I changed the bananas to be so
small.
Because they take up so much space.
Middle path does big range.
I think this guy up here could be our middle path monkey, to
be honest.
Oh, here we go, here we go!
Yeah!
Whoa!
How much are you?
20a!
Okay.
I want a second one of these guys like right here as like
support.
Are you gonna be our middle, middle, middle man monkey?
Are you gonna be our middle man monkey?
Our game's a super cold aura that slows bloons and freezes
water nearby.
Oh, that doesn't.
Here we go.
I don't remember what I said.
I think, wait, did I ask if it's zero to, or no, two zero,
two, two, 2520.
Wait, somebody's number.
Two, two, two, two, two, two, two.
Yeah.
The numbers.
8008.
You're so right, you're so right.
Yeah, the ground monkeys can be placed on the water.
But, but ice monkeys can be placed on the water anyway, so.
them I'm gonna keep them maybe the larger well larger radius
maybe I'm always wanting to do more camo balloons and lead
balloons you know what I mean I'm always wanting to do more
stuff that involves camo balloons but I think I'll uh the
upper radius okay all right now we just need a couple
thousand more
well that was easy that wasn't bad
even colder even colder yes 28 000 this guy just has nothing
ice minky that funny minky Ice Minky Junkie.
No, I just love them.
I just love them.
I just love a good Ice Minky.
Nice.
Okie dokie.
I think I'm going to make another farm so that we can save
up money to upgrade everybody.
Yes.
Me more.
Agreed!
I'm working on it!
Um...
Should I just do another...
This, this one.
Yeah.
So far so good.
Literally scratching his booty over there.
He's like, I'm so bored, I'm so bored.
Let's get this one.
Yay!
Get him!
What
does the ice glass do?
Oh.
Did anything happen?
Oh,
our backup supporter is doing an amazing job!
Good job, mister.
Awesome, awesome, awesome.
Scary but safe, yeah.
That's glass and ice.
Promote that, man.
he's he's doing he's doing an amazing job he's popped 145
balloons guys we're so close to 3 million we're gonna get
we're gonna get we're gonna get that guy today maybe how
many rounds is over 3 million balloons right we need more
ice monkeys to expand his range i think you have a great
point I think you make an excellent suggestion.
What is his range anyway?
Yes.
What if I went to buff him, though?
Wait, our Ice Monkey Wall!
By 100, it's 2 million.
Okay, okay.
Okay, that's not so bad, I feel.
Pump those farms.
No, I do think boosting the range is pretty good.
good too though like maybe something out here or oh wait is
this area workable no right here is but
i mean i could do another guy over here or something it's
kind of tough you could still do the ice monkey wall i think
i want to but i also want to have like i said the Maybe just
boosting a wall would be good.
Yueshin, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Near the nest, almost nothing of tax there.
Let's have a bit of fun.
A little bit, yeah.
I think I could fit a couple in there, honestly.
Ah, I don't know what to do.
I don't know what I want to start with.
It's like, do we do arrange?
Do we do...
Do we do?
Do we
do?
Go for the wall, you have the money.
Okay.
Wait, what is...
So, wait.
For the wall, if I just put a bunch of ice monkeys on
upgraded, then it would super buff him, right?
But...
Or do they have to be tier three?
It buffs the range.
let's put a let's put a couple
i have the money i have the money what am i doing oh no i'm
getting more support what is needed i'm getting more support
oh no oh no
what is needed i don't think it's in this range but that's
okay maybe it is then it they have to be tier three
if you get a top path village you can get some upgrades on
the wall for free.
I think, wait, if a village, I put it here, would it be able
to extend to them?
I think if I got the extender, it could.
One more for good luck.
So true.
Bigger radius, yeah.
Let's try it.
And we'll do attack speed, sure.
this last our last guy though that sucks did it hit you okay
it hits you
we'll do this too all right and also let's see can we fit we
can we can fit more we can fit two more guys in here whoa
what the heck
Casey Raptor thank you so much for the vlog Thank you, thank
you.
Get a second village for the first village.
I guess right.
The mentoring gives more range?
Oh, it does.
Oh.
Oh, my gosh.
Are we...
Okay.
I'm going to put a monkey here so that we can...
and get the range.
The additional range here.
Let's try.
What do I pay you for?
He's doing literally nothing.
Sick.
He's the receptionist.
The
ice thickens.
Free upgrades.
Wait, wait.
Oh, wait!
Don't I... Oh, yeah, wait, a free upgrade.
That's right.
Um, oh, wait.
Oh, I forgot.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait.
Hmm.
Doom.
Oh, push.
Let's do...
I have this guy as a middle path, but I think I'm gonna...
Oh, wait.
Look how cool he looks.
Top and bottom path from OABs and a couple of middles.
Yeah, I think that's honestly the best strut.
We have this guy.
We'll do another top pet.
What did I do for you?
Date freeze.
And...
Okay, hold on.
I have to remember.
Let's see.
No.
Stop it.
There we go.
Um, bottom.
We'll just alternate.
What did I do for you?
Wow.
of icicles wait that would be awesome that would be awesome
i can barely click the monkeys wall of icicles let's go okay
i'm gonna do it don't think i won't don't think i won't
i don't get more money though
they're all so cool
let's get this one
oh yeah I have my other free ones too you're so right thank
you um for you I'll do the same or hold on yeah I'll do the
same oh oops that was not free that's okay though it was not
free embrittlement wham bam That was extremely effective.
Yes, my free upgrades.
It feels so good.
There's a multiplayer for this game.
Wait, no way!
I'm new.
Me too.
60 rapidly approaching.
That's when we get the...
Is it...
Not the ZOMG, what is it?
How did you not know?
I don't play this game so often, to be honest.
Icicles.
I'm the most casual blooner out there.
Only multiplayer though, if you want PvP, do bloons battle
two games.
Oh, here it is.
Here it is.
Oh, it's this one.
We're going to keep going.
Wait, now how much?
That's okay.
Top snowstorm monkey looks like Spain goalkeeper.
This guy.
Huzzah, huzzah, huzzah.
And we can get some icicles in there too.
Now it's an actual wall of icicles.
Can I fit one more guy in here?
Oh, yes, I can.
Join the wall.
Sharma, thank you.
Thank you so much.
Sharma.
Level up.
Wait, are you max?
No.
Let's get this one.
Let's get this one!
Hope she survives round 63.
They really get you with like the false sense of...
Wait, what is that?
The false like...
Oh, I'm doing so good.
I'm feeling so good.
Frozen Burial ability immediately freezes and damages all
bloons dealing far more damage to already frozen bloons.
I'll try it.
and then suddenly you're like, I'm dying, I'm dying, and
everything is bad!
I'm, I'm, I'm, my finger is on four for if things go so bad.
Oh, wait.
Was that round 63?
Oh.
Life is so fine, then the DDT goes, exactly, exactly,
exactly, exactly.
Jeez, not Not even the reinforced Moab.
I do want to get this guy up to Super Brittle.
But.
Icicles.
Okay.
Now he's part of the team.
Everybody.
It's so goofy looking.
Why do we build the wall?
We build the wall.
We stop the balloon.
We got this.
What did I say?
What is needed?
Soon Ice Paragon.
I want, but we don't get as...
Actually, we are getting quite...
We stopped at...
Wait, we just...
We got to level 60 at...
What was it?
10,000?
Maybe...
ironically you're absolutely melting these waves yeah we
stopped at 11k we got 3k cents so maybe yeah maybe we will
be able to unlock some more yeah you get less xp on free
play so that's why i was worried we wouldn't be able to make
it but hmm i'm gonna get another farm
no no
try to get icicle impaled I'm trying.
I am.
It's going to be tough, though.
We'll save up for...
Oh, shoot.
I don't have any merchant men.
I have no merchant men to give me more money.
Impale Solos DDTs.
That'd be crazy.
Uh, Toppath Banana Farm is way too expensive to get with
just three farms.
I have, I could start farming over here instead.
Maybe I should have started, maybe I should have built them
over here.
We have a, could have a full line of farms up here.
Anyway.
That was all of us.
That was, that was all of us, everybody.
Why don't I wait here?
Additional 5% discount.
What's behind my head?
A wall.
There's like no room there at all, unfortunately.
I think you can you can literally put like one monkey.
Hold on.
I'll show you.
Wait, the game.
Uh, you could put like this guy A single monkey.
That's it.
That's about it.
I think I will start lining these up with farms.
I know you have to spend money to make money, but I did want
to...
I did want to save up for the super brittle, but...
We can also then get the money for...
Because icicle impale is how much?
30,000, so yeah.
I know
the monkeys each have different sizes, but we're only ice
monkey today, so...
Doesn't matter.
And we can't fit a farm there.
So that just, uh, yeah, all right.
More marketplaces.
Nice and cold.
Let's get this one.
Yeah, we got this one.
We got this one.
BFB, work together now.
Yes.
You can fit at least one more farm on the bottom.
I tried.
I really did.
here i'll move over i'm i'm trying i try that's why i went
oh no oh it won't fit it looks it should honestly it kind of
it kind of makes me upset that it doesn't fit because that
completely fits right there they're just being they're being
petty spaghetties that this this fits bad
placement of farms it's me it's always me yeah just oh this
just bulldoze the whole place down i'm remembering why i
don't stream balloons the
insults are never ending
We're washed.
Never gonna bake it.
I'm trying to get it pixel perfect.
My fingers shaking.
How dare I stutter.
After you play with the smaller monkey mode placement, it
stops making sense.
We're working together.
What's our... What's our...
17!
Wait, wait!
Wait, wait, this is huge!
Wait, this is actually huge!
I haven't, I just realized, I haven't done anything with
this guy.
What do I want to do with him?
Another
marketplace.
More bananas, I don't know.
6k left till super brittle.
Yeah, we'll just save.
Let's get this one.
Does Marketplace everywhere?
Marketplacing all over the place?
Essential markets too and you can afford it.
Yeah, yeah!
We'll go back to marketplace.
Yeah, actually I can afford- well, okay, hold on.
We'll get super brittle and then we will do the essential
markets.
We might be able to...
After this, actually.
So close, so close.
So close.
Ceramic breaking ASMR.
Super brittle on the ice monkey near the village.
Which one?
Oh, this guy.
Oh, oh, super brittle.
Sorry.
I was thinking icicle.
Wait, that would be huge, wouldn't it?
We'll do that.
Yeah, good plan, good plan.
Freeze, he's insane!
She was thinking she was crazy!
She was talking to the mice.
She was horribly nice, so she had to pay the price.
Let's go!
The ice thickens.
That was scary.
Let's get this one.
Let's get this one so So true.
So true.
Yeah, you go Ice Monkey!
87,000.
We can, we can double it.
Yeah, they're not even getting to the wall yet.
We can't, we can't.
The cockiness in this game though.
It's a killer.
It will kill you.
You have to always be on your toes.
You must always be on your toes.
Jelly bean, welcome back.
Thank you.
After 80, it's gonna get crazy.
Life was always.
I can't afford any more banana farms.
What are we looking at?
24.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, I'm, wait, I'm so excited.
Wait, really, actually, I thought we were going to get...
Maybe because we're only using Ice Monkeys, we're getting
that much, like, that much more XP.
Wait!
Freeze out the big ones.
Oh, okay, he's, he's, okay, okay.
He's going to explode.
Oh, I knew nice and cold.
I'm here to help.
14, nice.
Um...
We're not close enough yet that I don't feel like I need to,
um...
Like, I want to save, but...
I also want to make...
I want to spend money to make the money, you know?
So...
It got shredded, baby.
The wall...
The wall of ice, Minky!
Yeah.
Yeah, it's an investment for sure.
I'm new.
Did I upgrade another one?
I'm like monitoring our XP.
Because if I can upgrade these when we're not close to being
able to get the icicle impale yet.
The ice.
Let's get this one.
Keep going, keep going, keep going, keep going, keep going.
wait no i thought he said ddt for a second i was like no way
my fingers are on my ults my fingers are on my ults i'm
scared oh i just realized all right i moved i moved in a
funny way oh god what if we got another ice monkey you're
speaking my language you're speaking my
It's tempting, but I will not, though.
Okay, time to save up now, for sure.
Freeze out, the big one.
Freeze out, freeze out!
DDT on 90, okay, okay.
It's crazy because there's the wall, but, like, it just
extends.
They hit everywhere.
It's 30,000.
okay and then wait sorry i'm sorry i keep checking okay we
maybe next one maybe next one you guys no way oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god that was horrible that
was scintillating
i'm here to help next one next one we're getting icicle baby
here it comes
Which one, though, should I get first?
I guess it doesn't matter, huh?
Maybe, like, one in the middle, huh?
Oh, squirt, squirt, squirt.
Even colder.
Yes!
There it is.
There it is!
Who's doing the heavy lifting?
This guy!
Wait!
This guy seems to be doing the heavy lifting.
Or I don't think he, this guy has been here the longest.
This guy, hmm.
I think he should be our ice-cold impaler.
Frequently singing the chorus to Udama, she's somewhere
under my breath during work, very catchy.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
He earned it, yeah.
I think this guy earned it.
shoot huge icicle spikes that do huge damage to moab class
balloons and freezes them
this guy also super brittle needs to super brittle can be uh
upgraded next actually bf let's get this one i'll get him
i'll get him right now i mean you freeze out take one
still 154 by the way all
right getting to 20 27,000 is gonna be rough.
I'm not gonna lie.
And then, wait, isn't it also then after like some, some,
like 500 bajillion that you have to get to unlock the
Paragon?
There's no way we're getting to the Paragon today.
But that's okay.
We're chilling.
It's horrible.
Okay.
Wait, is it here?
Wait, DDT?
DDT?
DDT.
I'm lowly down.
as
a cucumber, baby.
DDT?
More like BBL.
Bye-bye, lady.
I knew
the ice thickens.
I think this guy he's also pulling in the work.
The others are doing well, but this guy will be our next
uh...
Oh, wait!
of the one icicle impale?
Wait, is that how it works?
Wait, I can't remember.
It's cold town.
There can only be the one.
That's right.
Well, I feel like we'd still made a good choice, to be
honest.
Let's get this one.
I forgot that it can only be one.
Freeze out.
Big one.
I knew.
Wait, how did I get this guy then?
Wait, I'm so confused.
How did these both become super brittle?
What is needed?
Oh, Silas gives you plus one tier.
Oh, no!
So I wasted it!
I mean, super brittle is not bad, but...
You could always sell it.
I could always sell it.
You're right.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, actually I will.
I've completely forgot about that being a thing.
I wonder, can I get him closer to the village?
Would it be wise?
Okay, so now what we can do here is get him to icicle and
pale.
What was it?
Two?
BFB, work together.
DDT, slow it down.
Valuable ones, because I get more money from that.
Oh, I don't have enough money.
Second village.
Yeah, you could use one.
One second though.
Let's die.
Oh, no!
Oh wait, no, I did the right one.
Okay, I was about to be like, no way!
I'm gonna stop!
We can do another village to help more.
out i
mean does he need it around 95 guys we're almost to 100.
i have my fingers
fingers on the ult
i think ice monkey broken
bf let's get That was horrible.
Did I just discover the meta of the summer?
All the ice monkey believers out there are like, we always
knew!
We always knew!
We knew, we knew, we knew, we knew!
She's too okay.
keep cool headed yeah i am i am i'm cool headed i'm cool
headed we're cool we're chill we're
chill oh wait we're already at 8 000 we were we started at
like when i did this one we had like 65 or something like
you know like x like nothing so we that were at 8 000 might
be time for more ice monkeys
I knew he
knew round 98 has the most RBE I
knew it starts getting dicey uh oh right now we're okay
though nice and cold nice and cold oh lucky fingers crossed
not even needed I don't even need the alt.
It's insane.
It's insanity.
Okay, we're at 10,000.
Let's get this one.
That was me.
Or slow it down.
I...
Okay.
I'm just going to go...
I'm just going to do it.
I'm just going to go into 100 right now.
Affirmation.
It can't be frozen.
Why not stay?
My power is full.
I'm just using everything.
I'm using everything.
It didn't work.
Oh gosh.
Oh no, wait, the DDTs are gonna kill me, baby.
No!
It might be over, guys.
It might be over.
Wait.
07.
Everybody 07 in the chat.
07 in the chat.
Silas says...
I did use the abilities.
It didn't work.
My power is yours.
Wait.
Feel the bitter cold.
07, 07, 07, 07.
That's okay.
They're breaking through.
That's A-OK.
I should have... I was a fool.
Again, this is how Bloons works every time.
You're like, everything's fine!
And then...
It's not fun.
You got the DDTs in the end, though.
Honestly, right?
That was pretty impressive.
At the very end right there.
That was nice.
Good run.
Oh, my bad.
Sorry.
Did you grow up playing balloons?
No, I started, like, last year or something.
Big Purple takes another life.
It was not Daijogu.
Joe Bunt.
That's okay, though.
Wait, this is crazy.
I'm sorry.
They're like, by the way, you're going to need to play every
day for the rest of your afterlife if you want this guy.
He's too cool.
How good is he?
How good is Desperado, if anybody knows?
Desperado's cool, neat tower.
Oh, I want him.
Evans, I wanted to watch your debut live on day one.
I even said it a lot, but I slept too early.
No, you're okay.
Almost fainted!
Oh gosh.
Please don't do that.
Old Bloom's Dream is where I've got a membership.
I'm so sorry.
Don't apologize, Rafa.
You're totally fine.
You clearly need the sleep and look you can see my outfit.
Right now!
You can see it!
Like I got my big oversized cardigan.
I can take it off and I got my dress.
Look, you just saw the whole debut!
What if I'm the size of the monkey?
Debut's breed one?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh yeah, the long hair, sorry, sorry.
Really need to catch up on your outfit stream in the karaoke
and the original song.
Why are you so awesome?
Thank you!
Desperately, huh?
Triangle?
Me too!
I mean, I've always had it, but now it's like more official
looking, right?
That's how kind you are, Minto.
That's my kamiosu.
No, I'm an evil ghost.
I'm an evil ghost.
Yippee!
I have to actually go use the little ghosty's room.
I'll be right back.
I have to use the little ghosty's room.
And I want to get some more water, too.
Stay hydrated.
Everybody stay hydrated.
Yes, yes, yes.
I'll be right back.
I hate to say this, though.
Right as I get back from being away from the computer.
But my tummy went.
Ow.
So I think I might need to go make some food for myself.
I went.
I think it's time.
for me to make some lunch.
So, sorry that is a bit of a shorter stream today.
One thing I really like about balloons is that is that I
like stress testing stuff, right?
Like, I think it's really fun that we were able to cruise to
level 99.
And if I had just added a little bit more support, we could
have gotten past 100.
It's kind of like experimenting.
It's so fun.
The smug ghost is there in every day.
But, um...
Aren't you part of the Sloppy Sisters Matara Nemi Collapse?
I am, I am!
I'm still not sure if I will be streaming my POV, but I also
wanted to eat before it.
Oh gosh, my tummy is browned, right?
So, um...
Since you got so close to beating that BID, here's a redeem
code for you in your chat.
You can redeem it.
In the in-game mailbox, and then you went in chat again.
Wait, what?
Wait, from the NK team.
Is this real?
Yes?
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
What the heck?
That's my birthday, GoGetFood.
Come put the mine.
Happy birthday.
Wow, thank you so much, Dev.
Try using the code in-game through the mailbox.
to confirm.
I will try, I will try!
I am going to go get food though.
Thank you so much everybody!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I hope you guys have a wonderful day!
I see you!
Oh wait, maybe I should try it though, right?
In the mailbox.
Redeem code!
Wait, I gotta find it.
Maybe I should pin it!
We were so close, we were so close.
Thank you so much, though.
There we go.
That's the code for you all.
That's amazing.
Thank you!
Big Minto love forever came for!
That was amazing!
Are there two Minto's on the screen?
That's so funny.
Thank you, Deb.
Thank you so much.
You all can also redeem the code as well.
If you would like your free Insta Ice Monkey 001.
And thank you for watching.
I hope you guys enjoyed Bloons.
I do want to bring it back just to play it every now and
then.
Bloons is such a comfort game for me.
It's just so...
so it's so fun it's so funny everybody gets so like heated
about it and that makes me laugh I'm like the least sweaty
gamer ever but people get so sweaty for bloons so I'm like
yeah let's get sweaty for bloons
thank you thank you thank you what are you gonna use next
time I don't know I still think I want to do ice monkey so
we can so we can paragon and But...
Hmm...
I'm smoky!
I want to still try to get to desperado.
I think I have to play off stream for that, though, for
sure.
Which, obviously, I like to do that as well.
I haven't used Mermaid Monkey very much either.
It'd be fun to learn how to use him.
And Beast Handler.
I haven't used very much at all either.
I want I want Megalodon Ectoplasm versus sweat But yeah, um,
for Palworld, I'm not sure if I'm streaming my POV yet, if a
waiting room pops up then you'll know your answer If not,
then um you can always watch anybody else's POVs, I believe,
you know, Doki will be streaming it probably
Um...
Doki will be streaming it probably.
Mataro will be streaming it probably.
Lymu maybe.
Snuffy, Anime.
Many, many other POVs.
I just, like I said, I might have to dip a little bit early
from it so I can finish up my work.
Yeah, sorry.
Busy, busy time.
If you don't, I'll be on Doki's, then I'll catch you there
if not!
Would there be Friendly Fire and Power World?
There it's not, and you can blame cowardly Matara Khan for
that.
Doki asks, she's like, do you want me to make the server
with Friendly Fire?
And Matara Khan said, no, please.
How dare.
She's a coward.
You can blame her.
I think it is for the best, honestly.
Tara wants everybody to work together.
I think...
She knew you'd do something otherwise.
What?
Would this...
Would this... Would this face do anything?
Innocent.
Gotta go possess somebody for food.
Or if somebody has a delicious offering you would like to
make.
I will accept that as well.
Thanks for a monkey.
I was looping your new song, Walking Outside Today.
Excited to hear you in the group cover later too.
Yes!
Barry, Bug, we'll have a group cover coming out.
What a time is that, actually.
Is it four, three?
Pure even, pure retribution.
Hold on, I go to Berrybug Channel.
It was making me emotional.
And I also realized I have not done anything for my six-year
anniversary.
Oh, it's at three.
Okay, so in an hour.
I have not done anything for...
Yeah, three PST, which would be six EST.
It's an evening for my sixth year anniversary, which is
actually this Friday.
Denso 2 first 3D live, Legends of New will be that day, so I
can't, obviously I won't be streaming.
But, um, I came back from shopping for food.
What did I miss?
Welcome back!
Um, but I do have a little something coming out in a couple
weeks.
A little bit of a late.
It was supposed to actually be Monday.
day I was gonna do my anniversary stream yesterday but
unfortunately my outfit got delayed so I didn't want to
release too much at once yes yes yes Yoki's waiting room is
for 3 30 oh I guess we are waiting for the steam maintenance
okay yeah I have more time to eat Okay, and then if I have a
waiting room up, it will be for also 330 PST.
So in about an hour and 15-ish.
Give or take.
Yeah, same maintenance.
Did we send that to yesterday?
Mmm.
Okie dokie.
Thanks, guys.
Thank you.
Otsumi, otsumi, otsumi, otsumi, otsui, otsui, otsui, otsui,
otsui.
Buh-bububah, bumbah, bumbah, bumbah.
Bye-bye.
See you later.
Bye-bye!